What if the biggest threat to your bank
account is not what you think it is?
It's not inflation,
it's not the stock market.
It's a 200 years old lie.
A single stubborn myth
from the 19th century
that political leaders
are still using today
to sell you on trade wars.
And no, this isn't
some conspiracy theory.
It's a
well-documented political playbook.
Today we're pulling back the curtains to
show you how this one idea
is still justifying
destructive economic policies
that hurt you, your
country and the global economy.
It seems like everywhere
you look, walls are going up.
We are living in an age
of escalating trade wars.
Just in the last few years
we've seen massive new taxes
called tariffs slapped on goods worth
billions of dollars.
Everything from cars and steel to washing
machines and solar panels.
The United States and China are locked
into an economic slugfest
that has sent tremors
around the entire globe.
And the sales pitch is always the same.
We're told it's about getting tough,
protecting our jobs and
putting America first.
Politicians stand on podiums
and sell us a simple story.
To be strong, a nation
has to be self-sufficient.
They frame global trade as a
winner-take-all brawl,
where if one country is losing it means
another one is winning.
They wrap these policies in the flag,
using patriotism and national security as
an excuse for these tariffs.
But let's be clear about
who pays these tariffs.
You do. The consumer.
And it works because
it's a powerful narrative.
It plays on our real
anxieties about the economy
and our desire for national pride.
But this story, this excuse for building
walls, is not something new.
It's a carefully crafted myth with roots
stretching back to centuries.
And to see why it's so dangerous now,
we have to understand
where it all started.
Let's rewind to the 19th century, a time
of explosive change.
The Industrial Revolution
was tearing through the world,
but not evenly.
Great Britain was the
undisputed factory of the world.
While other countries like a young United
States and a newly formed Germany
were struggling to keep up.
For both of these two rising nations,
Great Britain's power was
both impressive and threatening.
Enter Friedrich List, a German economist.
List looked at the popular ideas of free
trade thinkers like Adam Smith
and said, "Hold on a second."
He argued that free trade
was a great deal for Britain
because they were already the champions.
For everyone else, he saw it as a trap.
A one-way ticket to become Britain's
permanent economic junior varsity team.
So List cooked up a
powerful counter-argument.
One that would become the blueprint for
economic nationalism.
He said that for a nation
to build its own industries,
it had to protect its infant industries.
His solution?
Protective tariffs.
By taxing imported goods, a country makes
foreign goods more expensive.
This gives its own companies the time
they need to grow, to innovate,
without being steamrolled by cheaper,
more powerful competitors.
He even called it an Ertigumstol,
a temporary investment
in the country's future.
Now, this wasn't a totally new idea.
In the US, figures like Alexander
Hamilton had argued for
similar measures decades earlier.
But Hamilton proposed moderate tariffs
paired with subsidies,
largely for revenue and to give fledgling
American industries a fair shot.
List was the one who
packaged it, popularized it,
and gave it the harder nationalist
framing that swept across the world.
And on the surface,
it sounds pretty smart.
What nation doesn't want to be strong?
And just like that, the myth was born.
The belief that trade
barriers are the road to wealth,
and that economic
isolation is a sign of strength.
It was a story of national destiny.
The only problem is that once you start
looking at the facts,
it starts falling apart.
The core promise of this 200-year-old
myth is that protectionism creates jobs
and makes countries rich.
But history tells a much darker story.
The most infamous cautionary tale is that
of the Smooth Haley Tariff Act
of 1930 in the United States.
Passed right after the Great Depression
was sinking its teeth into the world,
the act jacked up tariffs on
over 20,000 imported goods.
The goal, they said, was to shield
American farmers and businesses from
foreign competition.
The result was an absolute catastrophe,
while not the sole cause
of the Great Depression,
which was driven by factors like bank
failures and monetary contraction.
The Smooth Haley Tariff is wildly blamed
for drastically worsening it.
Instead of protecting the US economy, the
Smooth Haley Act kicked
off a global trade war.
Other countries almost immediately hit
back with their own retaliatory tariffs.
Global trade didn't just slow down.
It collapsed, falling by 65% and pushing
the world deeper into economic misery.
This didn't save
jobs, it evaporated them.
Now, fast forward to
the end of World War II.
The world's leaders, having learned their
lesson from Smooth Haley,
tried the exact opposite.
They built a new system designed to lower
trade barriers, creating institutions
like the World Trade Organization.
This shift towards global cooperation
unleashed an era of
unprecedented growth and prosperity,
lifting about 1 billion people out of
extreme poverty since 1990 alone.
And guess what? Our recent experiments
with trade wars only confirm
what history has thought of.
Study after study on recent trade wars
showed that the country imposing the
tariff pays the price.
One analysis from the Peterson Institute
for International Economics
found that the steel tariffs
costs the US consumers around $900,000
for every job they created.
A Yale study found that the recent
tariffs cost the average American
household thousands of
dollars in higher prices.
Think about your
phone, your shoes, your car.
Tariffs make all of
these things more expensive.
But what about jobs?
The promise of bringing back
manufacturing almost never plays out.
A few protected
industries might see tiny gains,
but those are almost always wiped out by
job losses everywhere else.
Companies that need imported parts get
slammed by higher costs.
Farmers get locked out of foreign markets
when other countries retaliate.
The net result is almost always fewer
jobs and a weaker economy.
The myth that protectionism is some kind
of magic wand for the
economy is just that.
A myth.
It sounds great on a teleprompter, but it
crumbles under the weight of reality.
So if the evidence is so overwhelmingly
clear, why does this 200-year-old idea
still have such a death grip on politics?
The answer is brutally simple.
It works.
Politically, that is.
In times of economic anxiety
when people feel left behind,
the siren song of economic nationalism is
an extremely effective way to gain votes.
It offers a simple
story with a simple villain.
It is all the fault of
unfair foreign competition.
And it offers a simple solution.
Build the wall, tax the goods.
It lets a leader look like the protector
of the little guy, fighting against
shadowy outside forces.
This story works because it
taps into real frustrations.
But instead of tackling the complex
domestic problems that are
often the real source of the pain,
it redirects all that anger towards
people in other countries.
It's the oldest
political trick in the book.
Misdirection.
We see this playbook
running on the loop today.
The rhetoric behind Brexit, the US-China
trade war, and the rise of nationalist
parties across the globe all drink from
the same poisoned well.
They use these old myths to sell policies
that the evidence says that will hurt the
people that they claim to be protecting.
They sell a fantasy of strength through
isolation, at the exact same moment that
the world has become more
interconnected than ever.
Tearing up those
connections doesn't make you strong.
It injects chaos into the system, raises
costs for everyone, and makes the world a
more dangerous place.
So how do you fight a 200-year-old lie?
With the one thing that manipulative
stories can't stand.
The truth.
The solution is to understand the gap
between the political sales
pitch and the economic reality.
The reality is that trade
isn't a battle to the death.
Global cooperation has fueled innovation
and has lifted about a billion people out
of poverty since 1990.
The reality is that tariffs are just
taxes paid by the country's own
businesses and
consumers, not by foreign nations.
And the reality is that the policies sold
under economic patriotism have a long and
ugly track record of leading to
instability, higher
prices, and lost jobs.
When we understand the real history and
the real economics, we
take away the myths' power.
We can see past the patriotic slogans and
see the policies for
what they really are.
A political game that gambles with our
financial well-being.
We can demand policies based on evidence,
not a tired, destructive myth.
History has screamed a
lesson to us time and again.
Building walls leads to decay. Building
bridges leads to prosperity.
The choice is ours, but we have to make
it with our eyes open.
If this breakdown made sense
to you, then please share it.
The best way to disarm a harmful myth is
to spread the truth.
Subscribe for more deep dives into the
myths that shape our world.
Please let me know in the comments what
myths you think are worth addressing.
Thank you for watching.